este es el mismo problema que el del
vídeo pasado solo que me di cuenta que
lo resolví muy en automático en realidad
había una solución mucho más sencilla y
me gustaría contarte la vale entonces
vamos a restar y simplificar lo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado fue primero
determinar el denominador común después
hacer la resta y finalmente simplificar
pero ahorita vamos a empezar
simplificando para que todo quede mucho
más sencillo vale bueno entonces
observemos que en este primer término el
numerador y el denominador son
divisibles entre m así que aquí podemos
cancelar está m con un cachito de esta m
cuadrada y abajo nos queda una m de
manera similar aquí arriba tenemos que
el numerador y el denominador son
divisibles entrene al cubo cancelando
esto en el etna en el denominador
simplemente nos queda una n entonces
déjame reescribir esta expresión nos
queda como 6 dividido entre 7 mn 7mn
menos 55 dividido entre 3 mn
es m n muy bien entonces ahora sí vamos
a realizar la resta encontrando el
denominador común pero ahora va a ser
mucho más sencillo porque las
expresiones son un poco más simples
entonces aquí tenemos que encontrar un
denominador común ese denominador común
tiene que ser múltiplo de 7 y de 3 así
que debe ser múltiplo de 21 de 21 y
ahora sólo basta poner una mn aquí
porque eso se hace cargo de ésta mn y de
esta m n vaya a 21m n es múltiplo de 13
m n y de 7 m
entonces ahora vamos a ver por cuánto se
multiplicaron los denominadores para
pasar de 7 m n a 21 m n multiplicamos
por 3 así que si el denominador lo
multiplicamos por 3 el numerador también
hay que multiplicarlo por 3 de modo que
aquí nos queda 18 3 por 6 3 18 ahora
vamos con el segundo término para pasar
de 3 mn a 21 mn multiplicamos por 7
entonces este denominador lo
multiplicamos por 7 así que el numerador
también hay que multiplicarlo por 7 de
modo que aquí arriba nos queda 7 por 5
que es 30
vale ahora sí podemos realizar la resta
ya tenemos denominador común igual a 21
mn arriba nos queda 1835 déjame poner el
color naranja entonces sería 18 menos 35
35 y finalmente aquí hacemos la resta 18
menos 35 es menos 17 así que esto nos
queda igual a menos 17 / dividido entre
mn entonces fue exactamente el mismo
problema que el del vídeo anterior sólo
que ahora tenemos una solución más
sencilla en donde simplificamos primero
y después realizamos la resta